here with reaction Fox News contributor
let's give a warm welcome to
joining us on satellite out found our
friend clay Travis
and we'll both bothers me is they get
away with it and they just move on to
the next set of Lies they do but it's
starting to catch up with them I mean
the media's job approval has never been
so low the distrust in them but let's
back it up their job is to get the story
but with Donald Trump their mission was
to get the president and because you
lived it because we shocked the world
when he won not only do they not want
him to win Sean not only did they not
vote for him but they didn't expect him
to so I think it was the embarrassment
and they immediately got negative and
mean I called it presumptive negativity
there's a conclusion Donald Trump's
taking the Wings off of butterflies
let's go find the evidence but it cost
you the American people it cost the
taxpayers it costs the people because we
wasted so much of their money on the
Russia collusion investigation the
Mueller investigation the Mueller report
the Mueller testimony the two
impeachments that didn't remove him from
Office the January 6th investigation
just goes on and on and it's Relentless
to the point where I want to challenge
people watching tonight who don't wear
red hats don't consider themselves Maga
don't consider themselves very strong
political people I want you to ask
yourself how many sometimes you've been
lied to not just by this government but
how many times you rely to by the people
whose job it is to tell you the truth in
the media all in the service of getting
the president Trump derangement syndrome
is real we lived it there is no booster
there's no vaccine
it's just going to go on and on and it's
a very serious thing and it's not him
we'll go after someone else they'll go
after DeSantis they'll go after they go
after me they're going to make it very
personal it was very very personal for
all of us um and look I want to add a
couple to your unbelievable list what
about art what about our brave men and
women on the border whipping the
migrants it was never true
being told that you're whipping migrants
never true and I'll give you one because
I'm a professional poster the 17 point
Advantage for Joe Biden a week before
the election according to the Washington
Post ABC News poll in Wisconsin now
Wisconsin is a swing state because no
one's ever going to be leading by 17
points Donald Trump barely won it in
2016 and that turned around in 2020.
they had Joe Biden up 17 points that's
just not fake news or junk science that
poll is voter suppression because you
look at that and you feel totally
demoralized as a republican but do you
say there's nothing I can do maybe I
won't even show up and turn out this is
why you're kellyanne that's a great
analysis
oh hey Travis let's bring you into this
uh because we all deal with I can't even
count how many times I've been lied
about how many times people say I said
things that I never ever ever said
Hannity said no I didn't and I have
tapes to prove it but they get away with
it we're the only ones to call about on
it
you're 100 right and I want to build on
what Kelly Ann said because I think
she'll really appreciate this if it were
just poor reporting right if they just
sometimes got things wrong wouldn't CNN
MSNBC The New York Times The Washington
Post wouldn't they accidentally get
something wrong that was really
beneficial to Donald Trump at some point
in six years wouldn't they have been
like hey you know what Trump did he went
out and saved six kittens from the
Potomac River he was just driving along
in his golf cart and these kittens were
drowning and he ran out and he grabbed
the kittens and he dragged them back and
then it comes out it's not true and it's
actually a positive story that they got
wrong this is important and I want
everybody out there listening to think
about it because it reflects what the
bias is the bias is so against Trump and
so against Republicans and kellyanne's
right it doesn't matter if it's Rhonda
Santos or Nikki Haley or who ever the
nominee ends up being in 2024 they're
going to do the same thing and they're
going to make the same errors against
the Republican candidate because it's
about narrative over fact as you said
Sean and they never make the same
negligent uh misrepresentations when it
actually benefits Republicans if they
were just bad at their job they'd get a
lot of things wrong in both directions
it's amazing how they only get things
wrong in One Direction that's why as a
consumer of the media you have to be so
aggressive and so skeptical of
everything you hear from you from me
from kellyanne be aggressive in the way
you consume your news you need to be the
captain of your ship you certainly can't
trust the media you said Travis all
right we've got 20 seconds last word I'm
on a heartbreak
Sean the other thing was the mostly
peaceful protest in 2020 the guy on
MSNBC is reporting as the bombs are
going off behind it and people are
getting shot you see people looting The
Source all the Gucci you can grab in two
seconds just go for it Fox News number
one rated
I think they're jealous I think they're
jealous you get picked on because you're
the ghost
thanks to all these great people
kellyanne Conway thanks Travis thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else